ROBERT SAXBY: So what
we're going to do today,
we're going to
through TensorFlow.
We're going to have a little
look about how TensorFlow
works.
We're going to start off
with some basic understanding
of our deep neural
network models.
Then we'll look at the
architecture of TensorFlow.
And then we're going
to move on to Cloud ML
to actually examine how we can
start doing this in production.
So without further
ado, some of you
that attended the
last talk probably
already saw this slide.
I was walking past,
and I saw the yellow,
so I'm sorry for
using the same slide
if you've already
seen it once today.
But I want to just
basically ask,
can you put your hands
up in the audience
if you're already doing
something on machine learning?
OK, keep your hands-- well,
don't put them down yet.
So can you keep your hands
up if you're doing something
with deep neural networks?
And keep your hands up if
you're using TensorFlow already.
OK, so we got, like,
four or five people.
I'm sorry to you guys.
You can help me
out if I get stuck.
For the rest of you, what
I'm going to do first
is basically for
your understanding
of a deep neural network.
Just one of the
things that you might
want to do at TensorFlow,
which is really good at.
So the basics.
This is taken from a
CodeLab, which we provide,
which is available on our site.
So there will be a
slide in a moment which
you can all take photos of
with a link and everything.
But we're going to
look at a problem,
and that's MNIST recognizing
the handwritten digits.
And we're going to
look at how we could
do that in the most simple way.
So we're not going to go
for the fully convolutional
to make the 99% accuracy.
We're going to look at
the basic neural network
that we could make to actually
give us an understanding how
neural networks work.
So the first thing
that we're going to do,
we've got two layers here.
So we have the input layer,
and we have the output layer.
So this is a pretty
simple neural network.
It would be rude to call
it deep neural network.
And basically what we're
doing, those images,
those handwritten images that we
were looking at, they are all,
let's say, 28 by 28 pixels.
So if you stretch them
out into a long vector,
you get 784 pixels.
And what we're going to try
to do is use those 784 pixels.
We're going to map them to
each one on our neurons.
We're going to get
an output, and we're
going to try and predict
which number it is.
So the only information
we really have
is about the color, the
grayscale of each one
of those pixels coming in.
So ignore the function
here for the moment.
We'll come back to
that in a moment.
So the first thing I want to
emphasize is this X and W here.
So those pixels that we
just looked at coming in,
there are two things that
that neuron's going to do.
It's going to do the weight
and it's going to do the input.
And the weight is
basically-- it's just
the thing that makes the
whole neural network learn.
We're going to emphasize or give
less attention to that weight
if we find that that
feature is significant.
So when we're looking at
one of those neurons--
sorry for flickering
back and forward now--
all of those inputs are
coming into each neuron.
And we will have a matrix of
weights which corresponds.
And the first thing we
would do is a weighted sum.
So we will take the
value from the pixel.
So let's say we put it on a
scale of 0 to 255 or a decimal,
whatever you want.
And we will take a weight,
we multiply those two,
and we'll add them all up
for each one those neurons.
There's an extra thing
here called the bias.
That bias is, basically,
if you think about it,
if you go back to
math class, you
had like a y-axis
and the x-axis.
The bias is just basically where
it intercepts on the y-axis.
So we'll leave that for now.
But that's what it does.
OK, so in the previous
slide, what I showed here
is the softmax function.
The softmax function we will
come back to in a little bit,
but because we don't have
multiple layers in our network,
we want to do some activation.
But at the same time, we
want to work out probability.
So softmax has these
nice properties
that will actually
take our scores,
like that value of
that weighted sum,
and turn it into a
probability for us.
If we were to add
more layers, which
is what we're going to do
here, and this is, well,
as it states, it's overkill.
It's not how you should
tackle this problem.
But just to give you an
understanding of how you could
tackle this problem,
what we're doing now
is adding more layers
to our neural network.
So the idea of deep,
having multiple layers
comes into play.
And in each one of
these layers we're
going to do the same thing.
We're going to take
the value, the input.
We're going to add a weight.
We're going to do
that multiplication,
and we're going to
sum it up, and we'll
pass it through to the next
one, and so on and so forth.
Inside each of
those neurons, we're
going to have an
activation function.
One function that you
might use is sigmoid.
Lights just changed.
OK, what does an
activation function do?
What's it all about?
So let's have a look ahead.
At the top row here, these
are all the different kinds
of, like they say, the
common activation function.
The most common
activation function, well,
let's say the most easy
activation function, not
the least and the most common,
but the most easy is identity.
You know, what you
put in, you get out.
So you put in 10,
you get back 10.
You put in minus
10, you get back 10.
If we look at sigmoid,
so it's basically
mapping in between
space of 0 to 1.
And it's kind of saying,
well, actually we're
going to squash it a bit.
Notices the values at the
tail end or at the front,
they actually are going to
kind of get to the same value.
And the stuff that's
in the middle,
we're going to kind of
emphasize a bit more.
That's closer to the identity.
A lot of neural networks
actually use sigmoid.
What we've actually
found with imaging
is ReLu, which is
this function here,
which is almost the
same as identity,
except for anything
that's negative,
we're just going to put to zero.
It's a function that works
quite well in that space.
The reason why that
one works well--
so how it was
explained to me, it
was explained to me that
if you look at sigmoid,
that's how we kind of
interpreted the world.
But when they started
to look at some
of the biological
functions of eye cells
and this kind of stuff,
they saw that the signal
that was actually coming
through was more akin to this.
So they thought well,
let's give it a try.
And they did.
And it seems to work
quite well in imaging.
And you can obviously
think for the features
that you're trying to
get, you're not losing
or you're not kind
of, let's say,
making that information at the
front end all flat anymore.
So you're not bringing it
all into the same space.
You're not losing that emphasis.
I think that the better
explanation I heard was they
tried it, it seemed
to work well,
and that was good to go further.
The softmax function
at the bottom,
basically this is
a function that's
going to allow us to take
our scores or our logits,
and we're going to do
something to actually turn that
into probabilities.
So this is a good
function to have
at the end to use in a
classification space.
So we've got our scores,
which is the top row.
And we've got our--
sorry, we've got our scores,
which is the bottom row.
I'm going to say this around
the wrong way again, aren't I?
We have our scores,
which is the bottom row.
And what we want
to compare it to
is what the actual values are.
But the actual value in this
case is a handwritten digit,
so it's anywhere
between 0 and 9.
So we want to compare those.
So we're going to do something
called one hot encoding.
So there's basically, a 6
becomes a load of zeros and a 1
and then a few zeros, a
5, well, you can imagine.
You can just look at
this and you can see why.
So 9 is going to be 000,
and then 1 at the end,
and 0 is going to be
one on a tail end of 9s.
And then what we can do is
actually take the actual value
and we can take
the probabilities,
and we can work out the
distance between those two.
In neural networks, a popular
function is cross-entropy.
What cross-entropy is basically
looking at is how much noise
or how much information is
there between the actual value
and what we predicted.
We want to minimize that.
Another function that you
might have heard in this space
that you might want
to use is like the sum
of squared errors, which is a
different function, which kind
of works better in this space.
So, again, it's
a trial and error
to work out what's
good to apply.
So what you're going to do, if
you can imagine that we've--
let's say we
predicted a 6 and we
look at the distance between
6 and the 0.9 and the 1,
that distance is
0.1, but we would
do that for all of
the things that we
predicted it might have been.
And if those distances
are bigger, well,
that's going to add up, or
it's going to multiply out,
and it's going to be
a worse prediction.
The last part of this--
so if you imagine,
we've actually gone through now
like the whole forward pass.
So basically what we've
done, we taken input.
We've multiplied
it by some weights.
We've done our activations.
And then we've come
to this function where
we calculate the loss or the
amount of information that's
left over.
Now we need to go and
basically train our network
and make it better.
So we need to go and work out
what those weights should be.
How we do that is backward
propagation and the function--
basically it's a descent
algorithm, a gradient descent.
So what you'd-- if you imagine
all of those features mapped
in space, and what we're trying
to do is work out what is
the optimum.
Now we have this nice property.
We have a gradient
that goes down,
so it has gradient descent.
So we're trying to find out
what the global minimum is,
where we have the best fit.
And we will basically retrain
that network over and over
again to work out what the
best set of weights are,
and that will become
our neural network.
So this was super fast,
because the rest of the talk,
I'm going to explain
on architecture
and how to actually
start getting
this stuff into production.
This slide here, you can go
to the GitHub link there.
You can also go to the
link here on Google Doc.
And you can find
this whole tutorial,
and you can walk through
it and have a go,
and each of those
steps are explained.
The mathematics behind is
explained a little bit more as
well.
So if that's what you
find most interesting
and you want to get out
from this, that's a place
I would recommend to start.
So machine learning-- what makes
successful machine learning?
It's gonna be fun with
a fan in the moment.
Successful machine
learning, I mean,
as Tino said in the
keynote this morning,
these things have been
around for a long time.
Why are we hearing so much
about it in the last years?
It comes down to storage
and computational power.
So in that space, you know,
we want to have lots of data.
You need lots of storage.
We want to be able to
actually process this data,
because if we're going to be
doing all this multiplications
and everything with
lots and lots of data
and complicated
networks, there's going
to be a lot of passes involved.
So yeah, we need to
have computational power
to actually work
through our good models.
The good model part
is something I've
had a few discussions
with today even.
And I'm kind of just like,
OK, what is this democratizing
AI all about?
What is it exactly we're
trying to do in that space?
Well, put your hand up--
I'm going to keep making
people put their hands up.
Put your hand up
if you use Linux.
OK, that's a lot more
than the first one.
Put your hand up if you actually
contributed to the Linux code
base.
One, two, right, we'll
have a chat later.
Very interested to
know what you've done.
So my point here is
everyone's using Linux.
Everyone 's building their
stuff on top of Linux,
yet out of this
whole audience here,
there are two people in
the audience that actually
contributed to Linux itself.
In the same way, I
think we can start
looking at machine learning.
That's the space
we're moving into.
There are a lot of
people that spend
a lot of time studying math,
studying machine learning
to actually give us
the tools that we need
to be able to do this stuff.
But what we're seeing now is
more and more people using it
and more and more people helping
to bring it to production.
So our way-- our thinking
along democratizing AI
is to basically bring
that into the same space.
Make sure that everyone
can at some level
start using machine
learning, can
start interacting
with machine learning.
It's going to become--
I mean, these are
the predictions.
You're already seeing it now.
We're going to-- in
a few years time,
we're going to have
self-driving cars and--
I don't know-- telephones
that do everything for us
and make us coffee or whatever
else that they need to do.
So it's going to be like
a huge part of our life.
I have two children,
and I don't think
my children are going to grow
up to become mathematicians.
Maybe they will, but
judging by what they're
doing at the moment,
I think the chances
are quite higher
around something
with firefighter and--
I don't know.
Maybe the other one's
going to be a chef.
They're quite young.
So they can look for--
but I do want my children
when they grow up
and they're in this
world to not feel
alienated from what's
happening in the world
and how the world works.
So I think
democratizing AI-- this
is my personal
opinion00 is extremely
important to all of us.
So we should all develop
some understanding
so we can actually understand
what everyone else is
doing in the world that makes
the world work how it works.
So that's important part
I wanted to bring across.
Let me grab the clicker again.
So I just told you what we
needed for a good machine
learning, for it
to be successful.
These lovely things here
are our new pods of TPUs.
Each one of these pods
is 11 and 1/2 petaflops.
So that's a whole lot of
capacity to train/ to give some
kind of perspective on that, we
take some of our more difficult
machine learning models that
we've used for translation
and NLP and this kind of stuff.
When we retrain them,
they were taking days.
With these type of
ASIC devices in a pod
and set up in this scenario,
we can actually get that down
to hours.
So that means that
we can really bring
the kind of real-time
value to what we're trying
to do with machine learning.
You know, something's
changed in the world.
We need to reflect that.
We need to retrain our model.
Having this power
enables us to do that.
And cloud is really the only--
I mean, the only space
where we can actually offer
that at scale to everyone.
Because if you think
how much money it
costs to develop an ASIC
device, I don't know the number,
but I'm being told that it's
lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots.
That's not something a company
is going to go and invest in.
But if you want to
train your model
and actually have it play
a part in the real world
when things are changing
and reflect those changes,
you might want to have access
to this kind of capacity.
So as Peter in a
previous talk mentioned,
we have two ways that you can
benefit from ML Google Cloud.
One is with APIs.
This is also a good
part of democratizing
in machine learning as well.
There are common problems.
There are common
capabilities that we're
developing more and more of.
Being able to share them
over open APIs for anyone,
any developer to
actually implement
that in their
application to bring
some new feature, capability
to the application,
that's a great thing.
Whether it's translating
something or turning speech
into text so you can process
something or understanding
sentiment, that's all great.
And if you're in that
level, you know, good luck.
It's a really great
space to be in,
and you will go really fast.
If you need to be
on the left, which
is the building your own
models, we have some offerings
there as well.
So the two parts that are
really important here,
one, is TensorFlow.
It's open source.
So if you have ideas, if
you're a data scientist
or if you're a distributed
computer specialist
and you say I've got ideas
how this can be improved,
you can contribute
to that project.
You can collaborate
with us on that project.
It's not just about
Google making something,
saying come and use this.
It's not ours anymore.
It's open source.
It belongs to everyone.
So come to that
space then, right?
And what we try to do in
Google Cloud-- this is true
of all of our open
source projects--
is that we provide
a managed service.
So you can take your
TensorFlow model,
and we're going to look
at that in a little while,
and you can bring it to
the Cloud ML service.
And you can train it.
And you can host it there.
You can see serve from there.
And if you don't like
what it's offering you,
you can just take your model
and go and do it somewhere else.
So that kind of, I can choose
where I'm going to do this;
I can choose where
I'm going to train;
I can choose where I'm
going to serve up from,
that's what we want
from cloud, you know?
That's the idea of open cloud.
So our job is to make sure that
we do the pricing properly,
that we offer the best speed,
the best performance, that we
offer the best security.
They're the things that
we need to focus on.
And you can focus on what
that code actually has to do,
and we provide you
a space to run that.
So this was the architecture
of the video, API demo.
So for those of you
in the last talk,
you've seen this
quite in depth now.
For those of you from
the keynote this morning,
just to give you a little taste.
If you were using those APIs,
how simple an architecture
can be, this is all serverless.
I mean, we have--
the most work that went
into this application
was up here to actually build
what the application should
look like.
The whole bottom row, let's say
where the magic's happening,
from people uploading
their videos
to a serverless function, a
little JavaScript function,
it's just basically saying,
oh, you uploaded a video,
run this API.
And then the API itself,
that's all servers,
and it's really like
a few lines of codes.
And then you have that
capability up and running,
and you're extracting
metadata from your videos.
And you can use
this [? patent ?]
for any kind of problem
that you might have,
whether it's turning speech
into text or anything else.
So let's have a little
bit look deeper now
into what machine running is.
This is one of my
favorite slides.
It's kind of--
this is what people
when you have a chat with them
think of machine learning.
You know, this is our kind
of common perception--
tons of data, really difficult
maths and magical results.
And especially that part in
the middle, that's like, oh
all right, I'm not
really good at maths.
How much-- what's
my role in this?
This is closer to what's go--
well, that was too quick.
This is closer to what's
going on in machine learning.
The big challenges to actually
doing machine learning
start with collecting data, and
that can be a real headache.
I'm a data engineer.
That's my background.
Finding how to collect data, how
to start organizing that data,
that consumes a lot of time.
And if you haven't
done that, you
don't have any data available
for you to go and do
your machine learning on.
So that's obviously
really important.
The next part that's
really important
is creating the model.
And then once we've got the
model, we need to train it,
we need to make sure
that it's actually
up and running, that the
data does something useful.
And then we can go
and deploy the model.
This workflow involves
a lot of time.
And I would say each of those
little hexagonals there,
they all involve maybe
not equal amounts of time,
but they all have
their own challenges.
Today we're not going to
focus on the first two.
We're going to focus
on the latter three.
But I'm going to let you see
a little architecture now
of how we might actually
do this in production.
So when we're talking with
customers, they'll say,
oh, this is the kind
of problem I've got.
How could I do this?
So the top layer is the--
let's say the input.
That's what we-- basically when
we're going to do the training,
and the bottom layer is the
predicting, the production
part.
So there are a few
things to notice here.
We're going to, the
service that we're
going to for actually collecting
data and extracting them
are Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
If you're in the big data
space and you want to hear,
there are talks
about that today.
Or come by the Instant Insights
little booth out there,
and we can have a
chat about that.
Or my colleagues as
well can talk to you
about how they actually work.
In fact, they're doing some
machine learning prediction
there, so they can
really show you
that whole pipeline
actually playing
live so you can go and have a
look and see what's going on.
So basically what we
need are capabilities
to be able to
collect data quickly.
Now Pub/Sub can scale to
millions of message per second.
Or you could have batch
processing if you want there.
Dataflow itself
is a Apache Beam.
It's an open source project.
And Dataflow will allow you
to actually do that processing
either in streaming or
batch in a unified model.
So you can kind of
treat them the same way.
And then if you think about
what that means, it means,
for example, you could
be training a batch
and doing all your
processing a batch
and extracting of features, but
when it comes to production,
maybe you're getting similar
data or the same data.
And you've got to apply
the same kind of logic.
So you could use that
same pipeline now
applied to your
streaming pipeline
for the predictions coming in.
And that's exactly what's
going on in that demo
out there as well.
Then we want to train the model.
So Cloud ML has the space
to train that model.
So we can actually go from
Dataflow and say right now,
let's go and train
the model now.
The data's available,
blah, blah, blah.
And once we've trained,
it we need to serve it.
Now Cloud ML also provides
you that place to serve it.
And we'll look at is a
little bit more detail what
Cloud ML does and
doesn't do in a moment.
So let's move on to TensorFlow
and spend a few moments
on the architecture
of TensorFlow.
Just excuse me while
I take some water.
TensorFlow, OK, can
you still hear me?
Yeah, sorry.
TensorFlow.
It's a system for distributed
parallel machine learning.
Its general purpose--
data flow graphs.
It has a lot of
words going on there.
What does that all mean?
And it targets
heterogeneous devices.
What do we mean by
all of those things?
Well, first of all,
this is a framework.
It's hugely popular, has more
than 50,000 styles on GitHub
for doing machine
learning problems.
That's a good space to be in.
Open source, great.
And there are lots of
people actually using this.
So when you go and you need
to work with other developers
or you need to employ people
to help you develop this model,
you've got a big
community of people
that are already using this.
So that's really important.
What's a data flow graph
and what kind of devices?
Well, let's go to the data
flow graph, first of all.
So just think of
a graph of nodes.
There are many systems out
there that have graphs of nodes.
So this should be a common
concept to most people
I would imagine.
And basically we're moving from
left to right in this example.
And we're going to do-- in
those nodes in the middle,
we're going to do
certain operations,
so matrix multiplication,
activating things,
the cross entropy, working
out that loss function.
So there are some of the
things we might do there.
So this is--
OK, nothing special yet.
The next part that's
really special,
which the way it starts to
get special is in the name
itself-- tensors.
So if you come-- if
you have a physics
background or
mathematics, tensors,
you already know what they are.
It's an N-dimensional array.
So why is that special?
Well, think about what an
N-dimensional array is, first
of all.
So we start with a scalar,
and we move to a vector,
and then we have a matrix.
It's kind of like a
table in a spreadsheet.
And then we go on to a
tensor of N dimensions.
Three dimensions will
provide you a cube.
So you might have
an extra dimension
there, which has something
to do with time, for example.
Or if you are building
a convolutional network,
you might have something like
different channels of color.
So when you're going to do
your convolutional steps,
and what it basically
allows you to do
is transfer data from
that one node of the graph
to the next node and retain
the shape of the data.
So if you couldn't retain
the shape of the data,
if you remember in
that first example
where we were
predicting those digits,
because we weren't doing
anything convolutional,
because we weren't trying
to take those little samples
and actually work out, we lost
basically all of the features.
So we only had the
grayscale really
to tell us what was going on.
So how many black
pixels were there?
How many white
How many gray ones?
Which of those add up to tell
us that this is that digit?
But we lost all the
kind of like things
like the curves or
the texture, you know?
And obviously, if
you're processing
more difficult
images, that's going
to be much more important.
So being able to keep
that data together
as we parse it through
those different node
is really, really important.
The next thing is it has state.
So we can go and actually update
some of those variables within
our network, within our--
let's call it our flow--
and retain the actual
value as we move onward.
So we can do things
like check pointing,
we can update biases
and that kind of stuff.
And the last thing
is to distribute it.
Wow, that's a little
tongue twister, isn't it?
Distribute it.
I'm going to get better
at that [CHUCKLING]..
Ask me when I'm off
stage to say it again.
So basically we want to say,
well, we've got a lot of nodes.
We've got a lot of-- we need
a lot of computational power.
How are we going
to split this up?
So TensorFlow provides
us the architecture
to actually go and take
those separate pieces of work
that we might want to perform
on one node or multiple nodes
and go and assign them
to different machines
or different chipsets.
So this is kind of
the architecture
of TensorFlow in one slide.
The bottom bit, the distribution
and execution engine,
that's where that
magic's all happening.
We've actually--
OK, what chipset am
I going to take advantage of.
So am I going to use
CPUs on a single machine?
Am I going to use GPUs
on a single machine?
Am I going to run GPUs
on multiple machines?
Am I going to have some kind
of ASIC device like the TPU,
which I've just discussed?
So all of those
things, we all think
we want to be able to
take advantage of those.
So that TensorFlow execution
engine does that for us.
And then as we move up,
we have some front ends.
So that's when we start doing
our mathematical or our machine
learning problems.
And basically, we have a
number of layers in there.
So the first layer--
the layers-- is when
you build models.
So the stuff I showed
you at the beginning
for the MNIST state set
to try and recognize
those handwritten digits, that
was actually built-in layers.
And like I said, one of
the things about layers
is that you're going
to spend a lot of time
wiring your model together.
And then you're going to
want to take your model
and run it somewhere else
on a different architecture.
And you're going to need to make
some quite fundamental changes
to it.
So that's a difficult place
to be, and it's a lot of work.
But maybe you need that.
Maybe there's something that
we don't provide that really
requires that level of--
it's also the best place
to go and learn stuff.
So if you want to
understand it, that's
why we show it in our CodeLab.
If you go through
a CodeLab there
and you actually do
that stuff, you'll
really have a good feeling for
what a neural network is all
about.
But in production
in our business
when we're trying
to predict things,
when we're trying to do
regressions or classifications,
or when we're trying to process
images or sound, whatever else,
we want to be able to turn
this around a bit quicker.
We want to be able to take
advantage of things quicker.
So that's why we have
the Estimator level.
Another popular library
which integrates, as you can
see, with TensorFlow is Keras.
So if you're using Keras and
you like Keras, continue.
It's a great library.
You can take advantage of
the back end of TensorFlow
to run your models.
Our Estimator is
at that same level,
so you can choose
things like, OK,
I want to do an LSTM
recurrent network,
and these are the things I
need, and you start configuring.
And if you do it
in that layer, you
can basically then
say to TensorFlow,
now run it on the
single machine,
or now let's go and run it in
the cloud on multiple machines.
So, first of all, you don't
have to do all the hard wiring.
Second of all, you
get that distribution
and those capabilities back.
So that's a really
good place to be.
But if you're, let's
say your problem is
a little bit more commonplace,
like a regression that you want
to do or a wide and deep network
for some recommendations,
and you think,
actually, I don't want
to spend my time
configuring this network;
I want to take advantage
of a network that's already
out there; I just want
to kind of bring my data
and see what happens, that's
where the Canned Estimators
come into place.
So we're really
trying to make sure
that regardless of the level,
even if you're actually
building these models, you
have these different levels
with which you can come in
and actually start working.
And on the Estimator
level, it doesn't
mean because you're
on that level,
you can't go and
build your own model
or do something that's different
that hasn't been done before.
You can.
We have a Custom
Estimator there.
So you can actually take
advantage of that Custom
Estimator class and start
building your model there,
and then use that to run in
a distributed fashion also.
So Estimators, if you're going
to be doing stuff on TensorFlow
and you want it in production,
Estimators is a real must.
So let's have a
look at Cloud ML.
So we spoke about TensorFlow,
what we're going to do.
And now we're going
to do some demoing
and actually look at how we
can get this to production
and what that actually
means because these are most
of the questions I
get when people, when
we're talking to customers.
I built my model in TensorFlow.
How can I now go and
run it in the cloud?
Well, let's have a look.
So I'm just going
to move this fan.
What we have here is some data.
And we're going to-- it's
some census data from the US.
And we're going to use it
to predict income category.
What does that mean?
We just want to
basically know, this
is more about the process
and how useful the model is.
But we want to know
if someone's earning
more or less than $50,000.
And we're going to
use Cloud ML for that.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is we're going to
run a model locally.
And I'm going to kick
that off straight away,
because it's going to
take some time to run.
I did here the low
core I believe.
While this is running,
we're actually
going to look at what
the code is doing again.
So what we're doing here,
we're using Cloud ML engine.
So this is the
API from Cloud ML.
We've built a model
with an Estimator.
I'm going to show you some code,
what it actually looks like.
So the important
part here, there
are two parts when
you're creating this.
One is the task, what
you're actually going to do.
And the other part is the model.
So the task is a kind of
orchestration of that.
And as you can see
in the model here,
I will scroll down a little bit.
I want to show you--
where are we?
That's not good.
I'm going to scroll back up now.
OK, here we go.
So I basically want
to show you here
the actual Estimator
that we're returning.
So this code here, this
is where we're actually
building our Estimator.
So you can get a kind of feel.
Zoomed in enough.
You can get a kind of
feel for the kind of stuff
that you would be doing there.
So we were taking layers.
We're saying how deep it's
going to go, that kind of thing,
what type of
activation functions
we're going to be using.
So this is still running.
What you're seeing at
the moment is that I just
installed TensorFlow in a
little Python environment here,
and I didn't compile TensorFlow.
So if I was going to use
TensorFlow on my own machine,
I could actually compile to
take advantage of my hardware.
And because I haven't done
that, it's just saying,
well, you could use any of
this hardware, you know?
The next thing I'm going to
do is launch TensorBoard.
Now TensorBoard is-- if you're
familiar with like Jupyter
Notebooks and those
kind of things,
you might use something
like matplotlib to actually
kind of graph out and
see what's going on.
And again, it's like
an epiphany moment.
So TensorBoard will allow
us to do that kind of stuff
and much more, but in
our distributed system.
And so if we're running
this in the cloud,
we're running it locally, we
can actually take advantage
and see what's going on.
So let's launch that.
And I believe the log
there is a census output.
And I'm going to
allow this process.
That's not good.
And I can actually
now come in here
and look up how
accurate my model is.
I can look at--
so here's the accuracy.
I can start looking at
the loss of the model.
So you can see the
training went OK.
Evaluation was pretty poor.
But what I can
also do is go here
and actually-- so
bearing in mind,
we've just used
an Estimator, you
might be interested in
actually, OK, what's actually
going on in that network?
What have I actually built?
So it will give you the
ability to come in here
and actually look.
And it's going to be super
handy when you actually
debugging stuff to look at
how that model is actually
constructed and what's going on.
So TensorBoard is
included in TensorFlow.
You can just launch it.
And I've just connected
it now locally to my--
I've run that job locally.
And I will show you the
exact code for doing that.
This is great.
What slide am I on now?
I should be over here and
here and present again.
There we go.
So I really want you to have
a look at this API call.
G Cloud, ML engine,
we're telling it local.
We're going to
train this locally.
And there are a
few things that I'm
going to pass in
here, so the training
data, the evaluation data and
where the model is stored.
And as you see,
I'm using variables
to actually pass that in.
And at the moment,
I will show you
the file and what it looks like,
so you get a complete feeling
for what it's doing.
Let's quit this one.
And let's do [? cat ?]
on the local.
So if you look, I've basically
exported some variables here,
and I've just told it, OK,
look, this is my training file.
It's a local file,
my local system.
So you can see what I'm
actually passing through.
So here is the API call itself.
So you've got a good feeling
for exactly what we're
doing in a local situation.
Now we want to take that and
do something more with it.
So we just trained our model
in the local environment.
Let's now-- if I was to continue
in the local environment
and want to run it
distributed, all
I need to basically say is
that little keyword there
and run it distributed.
And again, I'm running it
in my local environment,
in my local machine.
So it will take advantage of
the hardware that's there,
whether it's multiple CPUs
and multiple cores or GPUs
that kind of stuff.
So that's an important--
that step I told you about,
configure it, like
compiling it to take
advantage of your
hardware so when
you're setting up TensorFlow.
So now you're saying, look,
run on my local machine
and just take advantage
of everything I've got,
everything I can throw at you.
OK, but it's still my
laptop, and it's even hotter
than I am, because
of the warmth.
So how are we going to
run this in the cloud?
Well, let's look at a
single trainer in the cloud.
So basically what
I'm doing here,
the part I said before,
local, that's changed.
So now I've got jobs submit.
And this is basically telling
it run it in the cloud.
Another parameter that
I've got here is region.
So in which region do
I want to run this?
Do I want to run it in the US?
Do I want to run it in Europe?
So you can decide
with that service
where you're going to run it.
And again, you provide the
training, the training data
and the evaluation data.
But those parameters
now, they're
not going to point to
my local file system.
So what are we doing?
Well, basically,
we take the data.
We upload it to
Google Cloud Storage.
And we just point
those parameters
now at the Google Cloud Service.
That's all you need to do.
So the example I'm going
to give you is actually--
with the code I'm going to show
you is actually how we run this
and distribute to
training in the cloud.
So basically we have
a concept there,
and it's called the scaled tier.
And you can choose at what scale
you want to run TensorFlow.
So do you want to run this
on a distributed system?
Do you want to have GPUs?
Do you want to have some
kind of custom setup?
Do you want to have to TPUs?
They're all different scales
that you can configure.
You can also configure
the worker type,
so you've got a
lot of flexibility
there in actually
deciding what resources
you're going to throw at
this problem that you have.
So let's come back here
now and have a little look
at what that file looks like.
So basically, the biggest
change is up here.
As I'm saying, instead of
pointing at my local file
system, point at this
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
That's all I've done.
And then down here, instead
of running on local,
I'm running that job in the
cloud by saying job submit.
So you see there's very
little change to your code.
You're cool to actually
interact with TensorFlow when
you're using the Cloud ML API.
I'm not going to run
that in the cloud
now, because obviously what
happens when you run something
in the Cloud ML, it will
go and say basically
try and claim resources
for you to run that.
That would take a
few minutes and then
it will start training the data.
That will also take the
time that necessary,
and then it's going
to be variable.
And we've got
eight minutes left.
But I am going to show you how
to start making predictions
on that stuff.
So I'm going to show you the
code that we need to deploy it,
first of all.
So we've made a model now.
We've trained that model.
How do I deploy that
model to Google Cloud?
So basically, the first
thing you have to do
is create a model.
So this command here,
will actually in our--
under our Cloud ML service,
will create a model for you.
And the second
command will actually
take your version of the model,
so the instance of the model,
and create a new version.
So if you think about
what that looks like--
let's come over here.
So here under Models, I've
created a model called Census.
The training I just did will--
actually produced a job.
And you see I ran that
just a couple of days ago.
So that job that I ran,
that was the last--
actually creating that
model with my training data.
And then basically, I called
that second command here
to create a new version
under that model.
So if we go to the models and
I click through in Census,
you'll see that I actually
have multiple versions.
If you think about what
that means in production,
it's that you could
actually take Cloud ML
and use it to train
your TensorFlow model,
serve it up in production.
You can then start working
on a better version.
Maybe you've got some new data,
maybe you got some insights
in the model.
Train that, evaluate that,
create another version,
and then maybe even
A/B test that so you
could point your
customers in say,
like, go and use that model.
Is it working?
Has it given you
a good prediction?
No?
All right, let's keep
using the old one.
Or if it's working well,
we can now switch everyone
into this space.
So you have this
framework that's
really going to help you
to do stuff in production.
And the last thing
that we're going to do
is make a prediction.
And that we are going
to do now, so let's
have a quick look at prediction.
And I'll make a prediction
with both models
or with both versions.
Just wait a moment.
Silence.
The demo gods aren't with me.
Oh, here we go.
So that's my first one.
And my second one should
be coming any moment now.
Going to wait for you.
There we go.
And we can actually see
a different improbability
in those scores there as well.
So let's go in and have
a look at that file
And basically what you see
is I'm calling the Cloud ML
engine to predict.
And here's version 1,
and there is version 2.
Let's change that
file for a second.
And let's go through it
and get rid of our version
1, which wasn't so great.
And let's run it again.
And we should see that
come back much quicker.
So the first time, I hadn't
been using ML for a while,
so everything needed to warm up.
But once that's in place and
you're making your predictions,
you can see that that second--
that that call again now
is much more fluid.
You're getting it
back straight away.
Let's go to the
last few slides now.
So that's how you
make a prediction.
So we're using
that Cloud ML API.
We've trained our models.
We've deployed our models.
We've deployed new
versions of it.
And we are now using it
to make our predictions.
So you can kind of see
how this site seamlessly
integrates with TensorFlow.
So you can do all your
work in TensorFlow
and now you have this tool to
basically do your production
pipeline as well.
Well, from training all
the way up to serving.
A few things to mention before--
the Cloud ML service has some
other properties as well.
So one of the things
that you can do
is hyperparameter tuning.
So if you're using
an Estimator, some
of the things that
you might want to have
is hyperparameters.
So these are basically
just parameters
that you're passing
externally to your model.
It might be, for example, OK,
I'm doing a recurrent network,
and I want to go to
so many levels deep.
So you might say, the number
of levels deep is so far.
Or you're doing a
learning rate that's
kind of like, I showed you that
gradient descent when you were
trying to actually optimize.
And basically on
the gradient step,
you're taking little
steps down to find out
where the global minimum is.
And if you imagine trying
to traverse a valley,
if you were taking
two big steps,
you might just jump
from side to side.
And if you were taking
two small steps,
it would take forever
or take a long time.
So your learning rate--
and you can apply decay
to that as well-- is saying
right, we'll take a big step
and then slightly less and then
decrease the size of the steps
as we see that that change is
having less and less effect
into our actual functions.
There's a way of
optimizing that.
So all of these things to work
out what the best learning
rate is to work out
how many levels deep we
want to create our
neural network.
These are things-- if you're
going to do this by yourself,
you would have to go and
retrain your model and rerun it.
So basically high
performance opportunity.
It's basically saying expose
those things as parameters
and then use the
service to say I want
to spend so much on my model.
So it's like, this is the range.
I'm going to go between
two levels deep and 10.
I'm going to go from a learning
rate from this to that.
And then you basically say
to Cloud ML, go and run this,
and you create a configuration
file with that configuration.
And it will
basically try out all
those different configurations,
and it will come back.
And it doesn't
just go willy-nilly
and try all those things.
It will work out,
OK, I did this.
That doesn't look
so good, so maybe
if I take a step in this
direction, that looks better.
Let's keep going
in that direction.
So work out what the best set of
parameters are for your model.
So you'll get the best
working model as well.
So the model that trains
the fastest, but also
the model that has the most
predictive power, the most
accuracy.
So that can really--
that's another
headache that you have
when you're trying to
train these things when
there's a certain scale.
It's because like,
what is the best?
Especially if you're in this
customer level, this custom
Estimator level, and
you're trying to say,
what is the best set
of configuration?
So Cloud ML actually
allows you to do that.
It will go and do that
experimentation for you.
And you can decide how
much bandwidth you give it
or how much money you
want to spend to work out.
So you can say this
is worth this much
to me, because I
want this accuracy.
Or it's not.
The last thing,
but I really don't
have have time to demo
this now, is Cloud Datalab.
There is a talk
later this afternoon,
I, believe on
Cloud, which I'm not
sure they're going to talk
about Cloud Datalab, but one
of the things--
they're going to show some
of the big data tools.
And I asked and I wasn't sure
if they're going to show Datalab
or not.
But Datalab is basically a
managed Jupyter Notebook.
If you go to our cloud
console, and you basically--
you can go in there
and you use Cloud Shell
and just do "datalab
create" and give it a name,
it will spin you up an instance.
You can give it a
machine type as well
if you think I need more power
than the standard machine type.
And basically what you'll
get is your own instance
of a Jupyter Notebook running.
It's connected with, well it has
Ungit running on there as well.
So you can connect with
a GitHub repository
or you can connect with the
Git repository that's actually
included in the cloud project.
So you can share that
with multiple people
across your project.
If you have a Jupyter Notebook,
everything installed there.
So like TensorFlow's
there, it's up to date,
all the stuff you need.
So all the kind of
good Python libraries
that you might be using, but
also the integration with tools
like BigQuery and Google
Cloud Storage are all there.
So basically by
using Datalab, you
have an environment you can
spin up in just a few minutes,
and it will give you everything
you need to actually start
building these models
and experimenting them
within Google Cloud.
So that's why I included this
slide, just as a callout so you
could go and have a
look at that if you want
to say how do I get started.
Where can I go?
And if you do that,
the Cloud Data
will also give you some folders,
which connect to our cloud
GitHub repositories.
And you'll see in there
stuff, examples on TensorFlow
on the Census stuff, on
running it in the cloud,
on running it
locally, on creating
different types of networks
from convolutional to recurrent.
So you'll see all those
different things there,
and you can actually work
through some of those examples.
So it's a great place to go
and have a look if you actually
want to start today.
And one more thing.
This GitHub repository--
so Google Cloud Platform,
Cloud ML samples, are
where all of these samples
are actually located.
So just go to GitHub.
Type "Google Cloud Platform."
In fact, if you go to
Google Cloud Platform,
you'll see all our
repositories there.
So if you go to the
ML samples folder,
then you will actually
see all the ones,
and the one I did today,
that I showed you.
So if you actually
want to go and see
how this works in a bit
more depth, it's the Census.
So it's up there.
And they give you two
examples with Census as well.
They give you an
example of Estimators,
as I just showed you.
But they will also give
you an example of Core,
so on that layers level.
So if you're like, I really want
to see what the difference is
in terms of work, you can go
there and look at those two,
explore the code, and see
how much work you actually
save by using the Estimators.
So I encourage you to do that.
I've got 39 seconds and
time for half a question,
so is there any.
One question, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT SAXBY: Yes, you can run
Kares if you're-- with a card
ML, yes.
AUDIENCE: How?
ROBERT SAXBY: How?
Come and find me after this.
I will give you some links, OK?
[APPLAUSE]
You're welcome.